the renewed push for americans to get
vaccinated against covid and in many
instances get vaccinated for a third
time the white house says 20 million
americans are now eligible for a third
shot of the pfizer vaccine after the cdc
approved its emergency use it clears the
way for seniors 65 and older nursing
home and assisted living residents and
50 to 64 year olds with pre-existing
conditions to get the booster six months
after their second shot cdc director
rachel wolinski also overruled an
advisory panel that had refused to
endorse the booster for frontline
workers including health care employees
and teachers
michael george is here with the latest
michael good morning jeff good morning
the biden administration was clear this
is just the beginning they've ordered
enough doses of the booster to be
administered from 80 000 locations
including 40 thousand pharmacies
we are ready to get booster shots in
arms right away the white house task
force prepared and was ready to give out
doses to 20 million eligible americans
even before the cdc gave final approval
friday as soon as i heard about the
boosters the only thing i want to know
is where can i get it the texas state
fair obliged boosters and first and
second doses will be available there for
the next three weeks
anyone 65 and older who's been fully
vaccinated with the shot should get a
booster after at least six months
the cdc also recommends a booster for
fully vaccinated 18 through 64 year olds
who work in healthcare or other jobs
with an increased risk of exposure like
schools and nursing homes
and all vaccinated people with medical
conditions including obesity diabetes or
pregnancy are also eligible for a
booster
at the white house the president
indicated it won't be long before
boosters are available for everyone we
have the tools to beat covet
covert 19
if we come together as a country and use
the tools we have but the coming
together may be the hard part deaths
this week continued at a rate of more
than 2 thousand people a day i want to
be clear we will not boost our way out
of this pandemic infections among the
unvaccinated continue to fuel this
pandemic
[Applause]
in montana where just 48 percent of the
population is fully vaccinated students
at the state university in bozeman were
still arguing over masks yesterday i
simply disagree that safety is better
than freedom oh i don't want to wear a
mask i'm vaccinated what's the point but
now when you see the spiking rates of
covid especially with hospitals being
filled right now i think it kind of by
not wearing a mask you're just
undermining everyone else's well-being
montana saw a 66 percent spike in cases
in just the past two weeks
now people now eligible for a booster
also include food and agriculture
workers grocery store workers and
transit workers but keep in mind this is
only for people who got the pfizer
vaccine so if you've got modern or
johnson and johnson you'll have to sit
tight for now what do we have any idea
when we might see it for modern and
johnson and johnson they're not really
committing to a timeline they're saying
soon but they're also telling people you
can't mix and match you have to wait for
this approval you can't mix and match
that's different from before all right
thank you so much so much michael